the dallas cowboys were one of the teams
to to which russell wilson was linked
and until they got dak prescott signed
and there went that
jason garrett who was the first head
coach in the nfl for dak prescott
appeared with morton anderson on the
great dane nation podcast here is
garrett talking about his former
starting quarterback dak prescott
you know uh you know we talk about the
special people the special players we've
had opportunities to be around and he's
just absolutely one of them you know we
drafted him in the middle of the fourth
round uh in 2016 and you know tony romo
gets hurt and dak comes in as a rookie
and wins 13 games for us and you know
the success that he's had
um you know leading that organization
you know he's got a fantastic player
who's going to get better and better and
better he's a fantastic leader and a
fantastic just person uh to have in that
position so really excited for him
really excited for the cowboys and for
the nfl i'm glad that happened
yeah uh
i i didn't recognize morton anderson i
hadn't seen morton anderson in so long i
didn't recognize him i and this is a
very inside dallas reference i thought
it was dale hansen when it popped up on
the screen shireen i hadn't seen morton
anderson in so long
so uh so anyway uh boy
i i can't i can't look to put that back
up you got to come up with something
better for jason garrett than
2007 assistant coach of the year he was
the nfl coach of the year at one point
so
okay they cycled they cycled they're
telling me that they cycled the graphic
but no matter what your cycle is that
that's that
doesn't you don't
don't put that up there uh all right
once had a paper route would also be up
there if that is is enough so what did
you make what did you make of what the
former cowboys coach had to say about
the current cowboys quarterback
well you know they still have a close
relationship mike and and when dak
prescott went down in week five
obviously they were playing the giants
and and jason was there uh supporting
dak and i'll say this about jason you
know i don't know that the guys cut out
to be a head coach some guys just aren't
head coaches he he didn't get it done in
dallas as a head coach
the jury's still out whether he's a good
play caller or not he did that in dallas
before he became head coach i would say
the jury is probably still out on that
as him as a play caller but i think as a
quarterbacks coach and what he does with
quarterbacks i think you say he's really
good at that when you look at how he
developed tony romo
how he developed dak prescott and you
think about
where those guys were or weren't drafted
in tony romo's case he wasn't drafted he
was an undrafted free agent who bill
parcell sean payton found and bill
parcells knew enough to to put him in
the game for drew bledsoe and and tony
romo lit it up but jason garrett really
developed him
and then he drafted dak prescott in the
fourth round
and jason garrett really developed him
so i think we're going to talk about
daniel jones shortly but i think that
bodes well if daniel jones has any bit
of franchise quarterback in him that he
has jason garrett around him as his
quarterbacks type coach i know that's
technically not his title but he's
really good with quarterbacks but
you know i i think they still have a
close relationship mike and i and i
think that dak prescott owes jason
garrett quite a bit for where he is in
his career for that big contract that he
got
and you make a great point about jason
garrett there are plenty of coaches who
are so good as assistants
they earn
one head coaching job
and then when that inevitably ends they
go back to being great assistants they
earn another head coaching job and
sometimes like with norv turner on the
offensive side of the ball wade phillips
on the defensive side of the ball the
cycle continues for a full career until
someone finally figures out
the best job for this person is
coordinator and that may be the case
with jason garrett but he did get
interviewed by the chargers in the most
recent cycle which stunned a lot of
people and caused some applause in some
circles not here of course
what we'll see if daniel jones becomes
what let's say josh allen became in his
third season we were surprised by the
explosion from josh allen last year we
we could be equally surprised by what
daniel jones does with saquon barkley
back and kenny goliday on the team and
evan ingram if he catches more passes
than he drops and kyle rudolph now on
the team
we could be saying hey this giants
offense is something and then jason
garrett's name is on more lists not to
help brian dabal the bill's offensive
coordinator last year but it could help
jason garrett become a head coach again
let's talk about the cowboys though and
it occurred to me that
one of the problems with the cowboys
under jerry jones is that
his tendency to sell to hype to talk
things up
there's never a season
where the cowboys have lowered
expectations there's never any tempering
of what people should be expecting
because you've got jerry jones
constantly creating the impression that
he's got a great team even when he
doesn't so you gotta cut through that
smoke and you really gotta ask yourself
how good is this cowboys team what have
they really done to improve how can we
trust what they've done defensively when
the stuff they did defensively last year
was such a disaster but more importantly
on dak prescott's side of the ball
assuming he's going to be a hundred
percent
are they really
a great offense right now i mean dak was
on pace for like 6 000 passing yards and
that's not an exaggeration but that was
only through four starts and into a
fifth game against the giant but we've
seen ezekiel elliot the past couple of
years not be the guy he was early in his
career they've got great receivers but
the offensive line is struggling to stay
healthy and it's not what it was back in
2016 when the cowboys were great
i is it is it fair to have these
expectations that dax healthy and the
offense is just going to take off
boy they do have questions my house
tyron smith's back gonna hold up and
how's that neck gonna respond
zack martin has a neck injury is he
gonna be okay throughout the entire
season lyle collins missed the entire
season last year is he going to rebound
at right tackle you know that offensive
line at one time was the best in the nfl
there was no question about that perhaps
one of the best of all time
but they aren't there now and maybe they
can get back there but who knows i mean
that's what the cowboys are counting on
right and and people are saying oh
they're gonna have a great offensive
line we don't know that we really don't
know that we don't know that that dak
prescott's gonna be a hundred percent
again we just don't i don't know how he
would know that at this point i think
he's running a little bit but you know
he's not to that point yet where you
know for sure that he's going to be 100
so yeah i agree with you this this is a
team with a lot of questions and even
when they were going 511 511 and 511
under dave campo they had great
expectations all those years you're
right because jerry was hyping it up he
always talks about the super bowl he's
not afraid to use the super bowl word
even though
the words because the cowboys haven't
been there since 1995 he's still willing
to put that out there and put all that
pressure on his team and on his coach
and it hasn't worked out since 1995 so
absolutely i'm with you it's a team with
a lot of questions of can they rebound
is mike mccarthy the coach for this team
is now dan quinn going to approve the
defense that much so that they're really
good on defense again it's a lot of
questions no question about it mike
the cowboys offensive line has become a
broader example of the dynamic that
applies to one offensive lineman who
becomes a pro bowler and all pro once
you get to that level
there's a presumption you're always
there joe thomas continuing to check off
pro bowl after pro bowl he may be a bad
example because it's not like he ever
had a dramatic decline but there have
been guys where the name says pro bowl
the performance says
maybe not anymore and i feel like that's
where the cowboys are as an offensive
line they still have some of the same
names most of the same names they still
have this aura that popped up five six
years ago but
between the performance and the health
or lack thereof and you know dak
prescott isn't patrick mahomes but he
does run around a lot and buy time for
himself which makes a bad offensive line
or a mediocre offensive line look better
i just i i think that our expectations
for the cowboys are too high and it just
occurred to me today one of the reasons
are too high and i probably should have
thought of this a while ago but when
jerry jones
applies that everything is awesome by my
product this is great approach to his
football team you're never going to have
reduced expectations you're never going
to have a lower bar that you somehow
surpass
everything is always positive and
optimistic and when you make a hundred
and sixty million dollar investment on a
four-year deal
in your quarterback who isn't a hundred
percent yet and there's no guarantee
he's going to be
you you have to sell even more because
that's the centerpiece of your offseason
that's the reason to be optimistic but
i don't know how optimistic i am about
these cowboys i don't know how i feel
about mike mccarthy as the head coach
after last year you know we've talked
about this before
the same folks who are bringing us this
fix to the defense
brought us the fiasco last year in one
year under mccarthy
they hired mike nolan and it was a
complete and total disaster so now they
got dan quinn and they're telling us
it's going to be great well what did you
do last year to make us think it's going
to be great this year so i i
yeah i've got real concerns
and uh you know we're spending a whole
lot of time on the worst division in
football today because they have
quarterback issues that are relevant and
interesting but the cowboys shireen the
cowboys uh even with dak prescott who's
arguably the best quarterback in the
division they got a long way to go to
get back to the top
yeah and i'll add a layer to what you
said about pro bowlers being pro bowlers
annually like they get that tag and so
they're automatically pearls
with the cowboys it's sort of the same
thing when you play with the cowboys you
come in with an instant name recognition
they have more night games prime time
games than any other team we know that i
mean it's documented they're america's
team i think they're you and i can argue
over that a little bit but i think
they're still america's team based on
ratings and everything else and people
want to see them whether they're rooting
for them or against them but the guys
come in and there's that instant oh this
guy's going to be a star because he's
got the star on his helmet right and it
doesn't always work out like that so
they have some players on there who i
think i want to say overrated but maybe
that's the case maybe they are overrated
but they instantly come in and have name
recognition and expectations and
everything else and they don't always
live up to it you look at ezekiel
elliott over the last two years since
he's gotten that contract he hasn't
played up to that frankly and he needs
to play better but everything with the
cowboys starts out they're going to be
good if right dak prescott if you know
he's the best quarterback in the
division if the ankle is good they're
the best offensive line if they can
overcome all those injuries they're a
better defense if dan quinn can get them
turned around but a lot of ifs with this
team right now i agree with you
and i'll agree with you that the
americas team label still applies but
they did get flexed out of a prime time
game last year for the browns first so
so so that so the the there there's
there's some wear and tear
on that sign that says america's team
outside the facility you know with dak
prescott who jerry jones was not going
to let go under any set of circumstances
as the quarterback and mike mccarthy is
the head coach and i
packers fans
look
we still have to deal with this from
time to time there was something going
on between mike mccarthy and aaron
rodgers there was some degree of
dysfunction and i know mccarthy said he
did cartwheels in the sand when he found
out that dak signed his contract but
mccarthy's got no choice if he's going
to be the coach of that team if he's
being a coach of any team he's the coach
of the cowboys he's got to deal with the
fact that they want dak press got to be
the quarterback we really didn't see
enough last year there isn't enough of a
sample size shireen
to
to know that that marriage is gonna work
yeah no question mike and you know
people point to the cowboys and say
well if dak had stayed healthy again we
don't know that this was a team with a
losing record with dak prescott as their
as their quarterback last year in the
five games he started they won two of
those and we all know they shouldn't
have won that atlanta game that was
stupid on the falcons part to lose that
game so this was not a good team with
dak prescott as the quarterback so
you're right we haven't seen enough with
dak prescott and mike mccarthy to figure
out how that relationship is going to
work on the field for a full season
because he only played four and a half
games last year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports